[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and job
where is our first thing that Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where me and my brother John we
answer your questions and bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon and also give you a dubious
advice I forgot that part how you doing
John so Hank the big news is that I do
not yet know the big news because the we
are recording this podcast in advance
and the big news is of course what
happened in AFC Wimbledon's playoff semi
finals which I don't know yet but I'm
going to come to you from the future and
record a little bit at the end of the
podcast that lets you know what happened
so there will be news from AFC Wimbledon
but there won't be any news from Mars
this week is that right that is correct
I will not be unless unless there's some
really juicy Mars news which you never
know but if they find life on Mars I
will I will call in and add my
additional news for Mars ok that sounds
great
well in the meantime we will we will
move forward in whatever way we can
now as this podcast comes out I will
probably be on tour so I hopefully I'm
also doing well I hope so I hope so do
you want a short poem for today it's a
very short poem it was sent in by an
anonymous listener actually oh
interesting here it is ready it's just a
couplet two lines of iambic pentameter
the daffodil knows more of spring than I
will ever know of anything ah hmm
interesting not bad right I like it I
don't know that I agree I don't know I
think the daffodil knows a lot about
spring I think that you may know more
about everything than the daffodil knows
about anything well yes that that's
probably literally true ah that's a good
point it's a good point feel of this
I've embarrassed my family with that
comment I feel like I feel like Neil
deGrasse Tyson tweeting right now hey
can we just move on to some questions
from our listeners okay I've got a good
first question
it comes from Valerie who writes Dear
John and Hank I have sent many questions
in although none have been answered oh
my god do you know any other good places
to seek dubious advice well I hope that
we're not the only place to seek advice
in the world especially because we do
get so many questions that we cannot
answer just due to the volume of them we
could do an episode of dear Hank and
John every day we are very lucky in that
respect we have lots of good questions
too many so many that even if you send
in one every week we probably won't like
there's there's a and a greater than
average chance that we will never answer
your question so I apologize to all
people like Valerie and second John do
you have any any thoughts on this well
sure I go to I I go to like Dear Abby
for dubious advice you know there's Dan
Savage if you have dubious if you need
dubious advice about love or sex there's
uh I mean I feel like the entire
Internet is essentially made out of
advice Yahoo Answers so it's a great
place to get very dubious advice I
sometimes like to go to like the WebMD
forums it when I have like a question
yeah whether I have a hernia because the
advice there is exceptionally dubious
well yes I would say that Google is
probably your number one place to go for
for dubious advice just type your
question in and let the algorithm decide
and and also maybe people in your life
are also a good place to go for advice I
like to ask or at least even if it's not
advice just say the problem to people
who I know so that they will have heard
it and maybe they will say something
useful and maybe they will not but at
least it will be not just inside of me
yeah sure so to summarize first google
your question then ask people you love
and then finally go to Yahoo Answers and
forth send us an email which we probably
respond to except when you ask why
aren't you responding to my email will
respond to that one apparently I've got
another question job sorry Valerie from
Miriam who asks a really important life
changing universe altering question
Berenstain
bears or Berenstein bears John I spent
an embarrassingly long time looking up
this but what tell me what you think
well I always say Berenstein bears I
don't know if that's correct I know that
it's spelled with an A but I've always
pronounced it with an e because that's
the way I've heard it pronounced what is
correct I think that we were raised in a
Berenstein bears household that's just
what my parents what our parents did but
it is indeed the berenstain bears and it
has always been well stained bears Wow
either one of two things and well three
things I've read a lot about this on the
Internet it's it's either that we are
really bad at spelling and reading and
we just see what we expect to see or
there's a massive conspiracy that has
lots of tendrils that go far deeper than
just the name of this children's book or
we this is proof of parallel universes
that we sometimes slip in and out of and
that there is this very prevalent
parallel universe that in which the name
of these books is the Berenstein bears
not the berenstain bears and and and we
constantly and in fact waver between
those two universes and it just happens
to be that those are the two most
probable universes and they are both
extraordinarily probable at this one
difference has has roughly equal
probability yeah other than that they're
identical you're proposing that Donald
Trump is the presumptive Republican
nominee and in both the world of the
berenstain bears and which it occurs to
me by the way that lots and lots of
people have no idea who or what the
Berenstain or Berenstein bears are they
are a family of bears that are popular
in Americans children's in American
children's literature and I believe
there's also been some television
programs about me actually I have to say
the books hold up pretty well
yeah you've read them too Henry now I
know to pronounce bear
Stane correctly but i am i have to say
of the things that i could be worried
about this is not really one of them so
let's move on to another question
deep deep agreement this question is
from hey-zeus who writes my name is hey
Zeus Hank this guy might be the new Ryan
I'm 19 years old and I live in Los
Angeles my mom moved from Mexico to Los
Angeles about 11 years ago I'm an
immigrant but feel like I will never be
able to call this my home because of the
way immigration policy is set up and the
hope for reform is dim what are your
thoughts on immigration and possible
reform I know this question might be
hard to answer so if you'd rather answer
this how likely is it for the next
president to not renew President Obama's
so-called dreamers Act through which
children who were brought to the United
States as undocumented immigrants are
allowed to stay here legally that's a
kind of a quick summary of the dreamers
act so the answer to that question is I
think the next president will renew the
dreamers Act I also think that there
will be comprehensive immigration reform
in the United States in the next few
years because we desperately desperately
need it it is unconscionable to me that
we haven't passed comprehensive
immigration reform we have a deeply
broken immigration system that results
in you know many many people being
separated from their families people
being deported to countries that they
never really lived in because they moved
here when they were 2 or 3 years old
there's just so many examples of how
broken our immigration system is I
really believe that our next president
and our next Congress will do something
about it but I also don't think that our
next president will be Donald Trump if
Donald Trump is our next president
obviously really everything is up for
grabs I have no idea what the US will
look like in that situation but I'm
really sorry that that you feel like the
United States can't be your home because
we need it to be your home it's not just
good for you
it's it's good for all Americans
immigration is an incredibly important
part of how the United States has grown
over the last especially 150 years and
it's an incredibly important part of how
the United States is going to grow both
economically culturally in terms of a
political engagement it's an incredibly
important part of our growth when I look
forward to the next hundred years so you
know I I really hope for a future in
which you can call yourself an American
because I think that is the future that
we want to be in as a country I think it
is a better stronger country for all of
us if that happens and I'm sorry that it
hasn't yes John I I agree you have
covered that very well and I want
hay-zu's to know that I certainly feel
like he's an American and an important
part of what makes what makes this
country this country I've got another
question John this question is from Suzy
who asks dear Hank and John I love to
listen to your podcast during my commute
often my bus is busy and I end up
sitting in a row next to a stranger as
the bus empties out and an empty row
becomes available should I move to the
empty row gives myself and myself a
passenger more space or should I stay in
my seat to avoid giving the impression
that I desperately want to get away from
the person next to me this is a great
question Suzy this is one of the great
deep questions of being a person on this
earth in the 21st century you know this
has happened to be on airplanes as well
where I'm sitting this to a person and
then right across from us there is an
empty row and I'm like I mean I'm gonna
leave I'm gonna go like it's a long
flight and neither of us want to be
sitting next to a paren like in moving I
give us both space and unless I want to
have some kind of relationship with this
person I think that everyone appreciates
that on the other hand I do always feel
a bit abandoned when someone does that I
think to myself is there something so
wrong with me that you don't want to sit
next to me I know that's not rational
but I do think it's oh I understand
Suzy's concern here
this is a yeah I do I do understand the
concern as well and this with what I'm
about to say is a completely different
situation but I wanted to talk about it
I was in a movie theater recently seeing
Captain America and during the previews
there were some guys behind me and they
were talking and they seemed like the
cut like they had loud voices and it
seemed almost like they wanted me to
hear what they were saying because they
wanted me to know how clever their jokes
were and there were there was even some
smacking of the popcorn bucket which I
didn't understand there's lots of
popcorn buckets smacking and I was like
what are you what is happening and so I
decided I'm not gonna risk it that these
guys are gonna be talkers and then I'm
gonna be sitting right next to popcorn
smacking the entire movie and I just got
up and I was like Katherine let's go to
another seat and we moved and and it was
a less good seat it wasn't a terrible
seat but I just I thought that I'm gonna
take my destiny into my own hands here
and say hey I let's just let's just not
risk it and I don't care if I'm gonna
hurt these guys feelings by leaving
their jokes behind I'm gonna go sit in a
quieter place is that the whole story
that's the whole story yes that might
have been the oldest person's story
you've ever told Hank like while you
were telling that story I think you aged
45 years but in summary Susie that was
really for me that was a real old man
yells at cloud moment anyway to
summarize Susie I think that we should
just collectively decide that when there
is an empty row if you would be more
comfortable it is not about the person
you're sitting next to or if it is it's
about wanting to make their life better
as well so let's just all embrace the
idea that we are going to seek that open
row when it is available to us and we're
gonna celebrate the space that it gives
us and that it's not in any way a
negative reflection of the person you
were sitting next to but instead a
positive reflection of how great it is
to be in your own row please yeah it's
good it's good it's good you got another
question for us John I do this one comes
from a
who writes Dear John and Hank my
boyfriend Matthew and I have been dating
for almost two years now and so far
everything has been wonderful with the
exception of one issue Matthew knows I'm
a huge fan of your work including the
podcast there's even a possibility he
himself may become a nerdfighter someday
our biggest issue to date has been my
Pizza John t-shirt for those who aren't
aware there's a t-shirt available now at
dftba.com featuring my face with a
mustache and then beneath it is the word
pizza why does this exist it's extremely
complicated I don't even know why it
exists at this point but it's a thing
anyway Matthew says it's hard for him to
kiss me or hold me Matthew says it's
hard for him to kiss me or hold me when
I wear the Pizza John shirt because
there's a large mustachioed man staring
down at him along with the
stereotypically American food item
printed beneath it he says it just ruins
the mood is Pizza John inherently unsexy
do you have any dubious advice on how
Matthew and I can continue to thrive in
our relationship without having to
compromise my pizza John shirt first off
any let me congratulate you on your
priorities yeah did you just ask the
question is Pizza John inherit
inherently unsexy as if there is an
option in which Pizza John is not
inherently unsexy of course Pizza John
is inherently on
I don't think Pizza John is unsexy I
think there's something very romantic
about being like well what's between me
and my beloved oh it's a middle-aged man
with a mustache and the word pizza III
Amy legitimately have had this problem
before where Catherine is like nope nope
not with that shirt on it may be a
little different because it's it's a her
actual brother-in-law but yeah it's
gonna say Catherine on that one but yeah
I yes I think I think that this may be
an excellent opportunity to change into
something more comfortable yeah you know
what I would say to be honest Amy I
would say that there are so many great
t-shirts available right now at
FTB a.com that don't have my face on
them and I would I would I would ask you
to consider maybe purchasing one of
those or many of them but I will say
that that Pizza John though inherently
unsexy is completely on in inside of the
boundaries for cuddling and I if anybody
feels like Pizza John should not be
cuddled then they did the problem is
with them not with your shirt I just now
you're making me think about all the
places my face has been which is
something I'd rather not consider let's
move on all right John I've got a
question here from Jared I like this
question my youngest sister is getting
married for the second time for the
first marriage my wife and I were very
generous with a wedding gift when we
didn't have a lot of money for her
second wedding my sister has created a
wedding registry and is making very
unsubtle hints to my family about what
she really wants off of it my family has
mentioned to my sister that she's
already gotten a wedding gift from all
of us but that has not deterred her from
hinting at more gifts my question is is
it appropriate to not get a gift for a
sister for her second wedding am i being
cheap is taking a stand on this matter
courting familial disaster thank you for
your dubious advice yeah I mean there's
two questions here there's should I
court familiar familial there's a
disaster and there's uh and there's what
is the etiquette and the question is
does does it make sense to you for the
etiquette to to interrupt and to create
familial disaster so yeah I mean for me
like avoiding familial disaster is worth
more than a gravy boat yes so I would
buy the gravy boat um but I'm not one to
stand on my principles as we've talked
about in the past on the podcast
I'm the kind of person who will who will
sell out his principles in a second just
to avoid unnecessary conflict yeah well
I think like this is kind of a situation
where that's probably the thing to do
you don't want to be like okay like send
them an article from a website and being
like here's the actual
etiquette of second wedding gifts don't
do that because clearly this is a person
who is important in your life and she
wants support in the way that she wants
support and that for her is apparently
has to do with gifts off of her wedding
registry if you want to make a stand for
second wedding gift etiquette then you
could let her know what the proper
etiquette is which is that wedding gifts
are about usually helping someone get a
good start on life and that's not
necessarily something you're supposed to
get twice and many people don't even get
it once but let's be honest is that more
important to you than you know like do
supporting your sister in the way she
wants to be supported if it's a
financial issue then you should let her
know that it's a financial issue and
hopefully she would understand that I
mean is that really the etiquette of
wedding gifts though like isn't it more
about celebrating the the marriage I
mean I think there's two reasons to get
a wedding gift one is to you know
otherwise you don't the idea is I guess
that like once upon a time people didn't
have silverware right when they got
married and so you would get them
silverware so that so that when they
moved out of their parents house they
would have their own silverware or
whatever but that doesn't seem to me
most of the time why we actually get
wedding gifts these days we get them to
celebrate people's weddings it's awkward
I have I will tell I will tell you there
have been a few second weddings where I
have been not that thrilled about the
about about sending the second wedding
present
so I'm sympathetic but I just think that
this is a moment to avoid this is a
moment to avoid courting familial
disaster I
I completely agree but I I do think that
wedding gifts and and in general wedding
like the idea of a wedding registry
where you ask for things to to help
build your new life like that's that's
what it's about and and also like that
is certainly a valid thing for a second
marriage and there are lots of reasons
why that might be useful and I'm not
saying that you know that only should
happen once but yeah I mean I read some
articles on this and it is generally
thought that people
going into second weddings are a much
less likely to have a registry at all
but they can also often be in different
positions in their life and there are
lots of lots of lots of things that God
mean this just seems like is this really
the hill that you want to fight and I'm
definitely not definitely not the hill
to fight and dying yeah I just mentioned
that because we were like halfway
through the podcast we hadn't mentioned
death yet so I had to squeeze it in
somewhere
good lord we've been talking about death
so little lately it's really distressing
to me you got another question for us
not really no I'm too busy contemplating
which Hill I will fight and die on I
mean at some point Hank there is a case
to be made that like you know I always
say to you when we have private
conversations that aren't podcasts I
always say to you is this the hill you
want to fight and die on that's like one
of my sayings to you but it does occur
to me that I'm basically saying that
there's never a hill that you want to
fight in die on and maybe there should
be maybe there should be a hill
somewhere I'm just not sure it's the
second wedding gift Hill I definitely
think it's not that hill but I I also
think that we all have to die someday so
it might as well be fighting on a hill
I'm gonna I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna keep
my eye open yeah what is the hill right
I want to find who died but don't die
the all right Hank we have a question
from Jacob who writes Dear John and Hank
why have there been so many celebrity
deaths this year or are there the same
amount of celebrity deaths and I'm just
paying attention more I think that there
have not been more celebrity deaths than
there usually are but that we are all
paying more attention I think that the
Internet is very death focused the
internet is kind of like focused on
death as a social activity or mourning
as a social activity and I think that
that causes every few days the death of
someone to appear on the trending topics
of Twitter and and the front pages of
our Facebook's and I think that is the
difference I do not think that 2016 has
been an unusually fatal year for
celebrities or or anyone else I think
that you life is
really defined by death and that it is
always with us and that we have just
noticed it a little more in 2016 I'm
glad to see other people coming around
to my lifelong ceaseless awareness of
the temporariness of all human endeavor
that's all I can say about it and I have
nothing to say about it because I simply
do not know it would be interesting to
see a statistical analysis there are
certainly outliers in any in any
stochastic system and the deaths of
people it would be one of those
especially well-known people which is a
much smaller group of folks than just
humans I do want to say that in the
movie Deadpool there is a death pool
where people bet on when people are
going to die and on that yeah chalkboard
in the bar where Deadpool hangs out yeah
there are a number of references to
folks and Ryan Reynolds and and I think
so there's Ryan Reynolds is the pic of
John and then right under John it says
Hank was who is the who has picked TJ
Miller and many people have guessed that
this is in fact a reference to Hank and
John Green of the vlog brothers who are
us and I'm looking at a navy club
article about that very thing and it
says while unlikely those while it seems
unlikely those names are a reference to
John and Hank green of the vlogbrothers
wait while it seems unlikely they're
saying it is if it's a reported fact
according to the a/v Club according to
whom I mean did the a/v Club like
interview the production designer I
don't know that says that on the AV Club
so it's there there it is well I I would
be delighted to be on a chalkboard in
the movie Deadpool that would really
that stands right up with winning the
Prince award in 2006 in terms of my
lifetime accomplishments and let's let
let us not forget be having the highest
possible score at Wii tennis yeah I also
I also am
of the five best Aero fighters players
on earth it's it's good to pick esoteric
things to be good at because there's no
competition well that is really the key
in my experience okay here's another
question for you from Kate who asks dear
Hank and John mosquito season is
starting in New York and it seems that
there are a few things more startling
and annoying than the sudden
high-pitched buzz of a mosquito in your
ear in the middle of the night do you
have any dubious advice about how to
block out this sound while sleeping but
also in a way that doesn't overheat you
and lets you hear the alarm clock in the
morning I realized that this problem is
more of a nuisance but it sure would be
nice to get some anxiety free sleep that
sounds awful I moved to Montana are you
serious I well you guys also have
mosquitoes in Montana I've seen them
they're the size of x-small yeah they
can't fit into the house that's true
it's hard to get them in the house
they've gotta try to like they've got to
try to like go in sideways so Kate this
is a nuisance for you but it is for many
people much more than a nuisance because
of malaria and other mosquito-borne
diseases including the Zika virus which
may be a problem in the United States in
the next few years I recommend a bed net
which does not overheat you and still
lets you hear the alarm clock bed nets
are great I recommend a bed net treated
with insecticide yeah those do work and
they are available I am so happy that
that has not happened to me in a long
time and I do remember back when we
lived in Florida that that would happen
sometimes or you know certainly at
summer camp and just oh that noise it is
the worst and they come right at your
ear I don't know why they do it but I
had literally this week had a dream
about that sensation and it woke me up I
I have no affection for mosquitoes
whatsoever Hank is there a reason why we
can't just eliminate the mosquito as a
species from the planet like we've been
so incredibly successful at eliminating
lots and lots and lots of species from
the planet why can't we just turn our
like human species killing instincts
toward the mosquito you know we did a
scishow episode on that
very topic recently and it turns out
that it's it's complicated but that
people do want to do it and and you know
scientists say that like there there
will be ecological consequences but they
probably won't be as significant as you
might think and it would be such a huge
public health win there are it's worth
being said hundreds of different species
of mosquito there's not just a a
mosquito and that's fat so that makes it
a little more complicated but there are
there are people who have ideas for how
to eradicate particularly the the few
species relatively few species of
mosquito that carry the most dangerous
diseases so that's something that we're
looking into actually I I think that
malaria is one of the problems with
malaria is that it's it's carried by a
lot of different mosquitoes but like
Zika I know is only carried by two
anyway we are so far outside our area of
expertise right now Hank pretending to
be a Tamala gist or entomologist not
etymologist those are people who study
the history of words and Tamala
whatever we're so far outside of our
expertise that I literally don't even
know what I would call myself if I were
an expert in this subject you know John
I have a question here that is kind of
an etymology question should we ask that
question wrink yes it's from Zooey who
asks dear Hank and John my colleagues
and I noticed a confusing issue with
Microsoft Word this week and haven't be
able to come up with an answer
seeing as we've progressed so far with
data storage like it's all in the cloud
now anyway why is the save icon
still a picture of a floppy disk are
there any computers left in the world
with a floppy disk do kids born in the
late 90s even have any idea what that is
I'm finding it difficult to understand
why there aren't more people confused by
this yeah no I don't disagree with you
Zoe I think the reason that it's still a
floppy disk is that we have sort of
internalized that as what saving looks
like I don't think that people still
think about floppy disks at least the
what was there was like a five inch one
that was actually floppy that we had
when I was a child would like the Apple
to see and then they came out with those
like three inch floppy disks that were
not floppy they were hard but they were
still called floppy disks which is an
excellent example of the very thing that
is happening here which is that the
words start to mean different things as
the things that we need words for change
like right when we're when we mean
ctrl-c ctrl-v and we say floppy disk
would in fact it is a hard disk it just
uses the same technology as the old
floppy disks all right so your so the
Save icon now has come to mean save the
floppy disk an image of a floppy disk is
now the image of what saving looks like
at least in Microsoft Word certainly not
on a Mac so maybe maybe that won't that
one won't stick around but all words
have context and all the symbols that we
use have context that's deeper than what
then what we associate with them now so
it's just it's it's all of human history
getting getting bound up and and hidden
in the you know with a current
expression of of our you know our
language in our culture that we have at
this particular moment in time
Haigh is such a good entomologist the or
the thing I'd like to say about this is
that Hank we've talked before about how
incredibly bad I am predicting the
future yeah me too and so the answer to
the question does anyone still have a
floppy disk slot is yes because I still
have one on a computer that I've kept
continuously running since about the
year 2002 and and on that computer it
has all of the outdated technology that
I believed would last forever um the
three by three point five inch floppy
disk the CD drive in fact I remember
when Mac first released a computer that
didn't have a CD drive on it
I remember saying well that's ludicrous
you can't have a computer that doesn't
have a cd-rom drive oh man I said that
Here I am holding a computer that
doesn't have a cd-rom drive I'm so bad
at predicting I said that about floppy
discs when when Mac when Ethel first
released a computer that didn't have a
floppy disk drive I was like no one is
going to buy that it doesn't have a [ __ ]
you arrived
how are you how am I going to install
Samantha on that computer exactly well
soon they're going to be releasing
computers that don't have screens or
even microchips and instead it's just
you know like a small piece of plastic
that's a 3d printed and then they shoot
it up your nose and it just merges with
your brain that's uh yeah yeah
absolutely it's right right around the
corner anyway Zoe the answer to your
question is that to me the floppy disk
the continued use of floppy disks is the
hill that I have chosen to fight and die
on I'm gonna use them forever I will
never give up on floppy disks what a
fantastic technology this video is
brought to you by floppy disks floppy
did yes there's oh shoot brought to you
by floppy disks floppy disks they hold
very little information and aren't even
floppy and yet somehow I have decided to
cast my lot with them for the remainder
of my life this video is also brought to
you by the empty row in front of you the
empty row in front of you now as decreed
on this very podcast yours for the
taking podcast is additionally brought
to you by that gravy boat that you
didn't want but God at your wedding what
is that for
why don't I just put that in a bowl with
a spoon and I actually quite like my
gravy boat and I don't appreciate you
talking bad about them because I believe
I bought your gravy boat at your wedding
I could not tell you and lastly this
podcast is brought to you by Pizza John
Pizza John interrupting romantic
encounters since 2009 beautiful job
beautiful thank you so much
Hank we've got to move on to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon but of
course there is no news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon so instead this is the
part of the podcast where me from the
future will magically appear to tell you
what happened in AFC Wimbledon's
play-off semi-finals
Hank moments ago literally moments ago
AFC Wimbledon in extra time at
Accrington Stanley won 3-2 on aggregate
they tied 2-2 on the night they were
down to one everything was darkness it
looked like they weren't going to be
going to Wembley that their season was
gonna be over but that is not what
happened instead what happened is that
Auto bio Aachen phenoix scored a
beautiful autumn by a walk and fen were
beautiful headed goal in the second half
and that sent the game to extra time and
then an extra time there was an amazing
run
I don't wasn't rigsy I don't even
remember who made the run somebody made
the run I think it was rigsy the
goalkeeper made a great save but who was
there to put back the ball into the back
of the net
but while Taylor the Maserati and Messi
the Messi for Montserrat with an amazing
goal Wimbledon in extra time go to the
playoff finals I'm going to Wembley Hank
I don't I don't know how yet I haven't
figured out the exact mechanics through
which I'm gonna be able to go to the
Indy 500 and to Wembley but I'm going
I'm gonna figure that out as soon as I
stop recording this podcast so the news
from AFC Wimbledon is that everything is
beautiful nothing hurts AFC Wimbledon
going to Wembley where they will play
quit Mathare dial add Wembley a one-game
playoff the winner goes to Ligue 1
unbelievable Hank can you believe that
incredible drama can you believe the
either good or terrible news I cannot
believe it John I also feel like we went
into it a little early but maybe not no
I guess not oh we've been going for a
long time woah woah oh geez I had no
idea well I'm very excited for your news
or possibly devastated by your news me
too I have never been so happy
and/or devastated all I can say is that
this either was a great season for AFC
Wimbledon and I'm so
proud to be a sponsor of their team or
this continues to be an amazing season
for AFC Wimbledon and I'm so proud to be
a sponsor of their team well that's
that's the right way to look at it John
either way you you and your team have
done great things this season and I
heart it well I'm so glad that it's made
you happy because just as a reminder you
do pay for part of the sponsorship yes
John AFC Wimbledon is Bay is what Bay oh
is that one of those internet words that
I've seen but I don't know how to
pronounce I hope I'm pronouncing it
correctly oh man you're such an
etymology Hank before we get to what we
learned for today I just want to include
one response that was sent in by Tessa
who wrote Dear John and Hank I was just
listening to episode 43 where you talk
about compliments I am currently seven
months pregnant so I am something of an
expert in receiving quote unquote
compliments that make me uncomfortable
Hank it is so true I don't know talked
about this on the podcast before but
people are terrible at complimenting
pregnant people you look you're huge
you're so small yeah she writes people
tell me I look small big uncomfortable
tired and like I'm due any day now I'd
like to offer some dubious advice on
doling out compliments that I think you
may have missed one please compliment
people on things they have chosen
clothes hairstyle possessions not on
physical features they have no control
over skin color shape size of body - if
you must comment on someone's physical
appearance and you don't it is always
acceptable to say nothing say you look
great with no qualifiers at the end like
for how pregnant you are
protip speculating on when a pregnant
person is due is an indirect comment
about their size so if you're interested
try asking instead of guessing yes Tessa
where's your podcast thank you for
the great advice Tessa you look
fantastic
no qualifiers so Hank what did we learn
today we learned that it is indeed the
Berenstain Bears and not the Berenstein
bears and that possibly this is evidence
of a parallel universe that we exist
inside of I mean I'm gonna say that
that's not likely but I guess it's
possible we learned that whether to buy
a second wedding present is perhaps not
the hill to fight and die on because
that hill is I actually forgot what my
Hill was Hank of course what of what a
brilliant decision by me I have cast my
lot with a technology that shall never
age and John we also learned that AFC
Wimbledon is either going to the playoff
final or not but we definitely learned
one of those two things
I also learned whether or not I'm going
to London on May 30th oh yeah and lastly
we learned that if you can't get dubious
advice from dear Hank and John there are
lots of other places on the Internet
where you can find dubious advice first
and foremost among them Yahoo Answers Oh
Yahoo Oh Yahoo Answers what's so good
never stopped answering never stopped
answering long may you answer thank you
for listening to this podcast called
dear Hank and John I'm Hank green that
other guy is John Green and his podcast
is edited by Nicholas Jenkins our intern
is Claudia Morales we get lots of
question help from rosianna halse rojas
you can email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com you can also send us questions
via the Twitter where I am Hank green
nope I get that wrong every time I do
not know my own name where I am John
Green Hank is Hank green you can use the
hashtag dear Hank and John thank you
again for listening our theme music by
the way gunnarolla forgot about that
thank you again for listening as we say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]